how's it going everybody and welcome to
this week's episode of Theory Thursday
my segment where you all submit your
theories I choose five to go over each
week you all vote for which one you
thought was your favorite and then at
the end of the month you all vote on
which one you thought was your favorite
of the month and congrats to last week's
winner theory number two YouTube user
Mysterio one two six four is now entered
to be eligible for the monthly prize and
right now the monthly prize is two imax
tickets so you can go see spider-man far
from home in IMAX or go watch Avengers
in Game and IMAX again if you're new to
Theory Thursdays and you would like to
submit your own theory for a chance to
end up in an episode you can find the
email to send it to and the instructions
in the description down below alright
it's time to dive into some theories
theory number one comes from yes beardo
and he has a theory about Loki and
Mysterio his theory is that when Loki
stole the tesseract and Avengers in game
the branch universe he created is the
same universe that Mysterio was from in
this universe Loki could have ended up
ruling over the people of Earth or
simply just some followers on earth that
practiced the art of Illusion which is
what Loki is known for Mysterio could be
one of these followers and could be
using his own illusion techniques
combined with his own tech to become the
villain that we see in spider-man far
from home in his universe perhaps he
already has a hatred for spider-man
which resides there this is an
interesting theory and a good take on
what happened to Loki after he got the
tesseract and Avengers in game the
directors and the writers already
confirmed that Loki did in fact create
an alternate timeline and in this
timeline he escaped and he has the space
stone
who knows what Loki could do with the
power of the space stone and Loki is the
master of illusion and Mysterio is all
about illusion as well and since
spider-man far from home is introducing
the multiverse perhaps there is some
sort of a connection between Loki and
Mysterio so that's it for Theory number
one let's go to theory number two theory
number two comes from Mohammed Jafar who
has a theory about red skull after
avengers endgame Mohammed says that Red
Skull was cursed to be a guide for
people who seek the soul stone but now
since Black Widow sacrificed herself and
Hawkeye got the soul stone the soul
stone is no longer there
on Vermeer which means Red Skull is free
and now that Red Skull is free he could
end up being a villain in the Falcon and
Winter Soldier series this theory does
have some merit to it because according
to the rusev brothers Red Skull is
actually free they didn't say this in
Avengers in game but after Avengers
Infinity Ward they did say that Red
Skull was free now that phantos had the
sole stone and Red Skull is actually
free in the main timeline FEI knows
getting the sole stone set Red Skull
free so there is a chance that he could
end up in the Falcon and Winter Soldier
series especially since they're both
directly connected to Captain America
and now Sam technically is Captain
America and of course Red Skull is a
classic Captain America villain so I
wouldn't be surprised if we did run into
Red Skull at some point in the Falcon
and Winter Soldier series so that does
it for theory number two on to theory
number three theory number three comes
from Georgie Barris lovara knov and he
has a theory about there being multiple
Spider Man from multiple universes in
Spider Man far from home Georgie states
that in the Spider Man far from home
trailers in the clips that we've got and
we've seen Peter Parker where multiple
spider-man costumes his original
spider-man costume the iron spider
costume the stealth suit and many more
and we know that Mysterio comes from
another universe and Georgie's theory is
that what if we are actually seeing
other spider-man from other universes
perhaps Peter isn't doing costume
changes perhaps were actually seen other
spider-man from different universes
if Mysterio is really coming from
another universe this could make sense
especially if this is going to be a big
part about spider-man far from home
introducing the multiverse we just had
spider-man into the spider verse come
out where they did this exact thing
could Sony and Marvel be planning to do
this in spider-man far from home
I'm sure fans would love to see multiple
different spider-man show up in
spider-man far from home imagine seeing
all of them fighting Mysterio and the
elementals all together and really since
they're introducing the multiverse and
spider-man far from home anything is
possible
so that's theory number three on to
Theory number four theory number four
comes from Alfredo Moscow so and
Alfredo's theory states that there won't
be a major villain teased in phase four
like they did for Thanos but instead
what will be teased is the multiverse on
a collision course the build-up to this
will introduce the
Fantastic Four x-men and maybe
characters like spider-man 2099
spider-gwen she-hulk er any offshoot
characters once they start getting into
the later phases the true villain could
be introduced which I think would be
Doctor Doom and while the heroes try and
stop the multiverse collision Doctor
Doom steals the powers of the beyonders
and creates the battle world and the
collision of the multiverse happens and
in that movie everyone really dies
except a handful of heroes then in
battle world we will see famous again
and maybe even see the Phoenix force in
Wolverine or Cyclops and then in the
last movie we will see a team-up of the
super heroes and the super villains to
go against the godlike Doctor Doom with
all of the beyonders powers this would
certainly be absolutely insane to see
happen but I think everybody would love
it and I think once we heard multiverse
a lot of people started to fake
battleworld
and if you want an insanely huge event
something that Marvel has to do to
outperform Avengers infinity war and
Avengers in game battle world is
definitely something that could do that
and then the heroes and the villains
teaming up to go fight Doctor Doom
that's something that people have been
waiting for to see on-screen for a super
long time now and now that the Disney
Fox deal is done and the multiverse has
been introduced hey we could see it
happen one day so that's it for Theory
number 4 on to the last and final theory
number 5 theory number 5 comes from Amir
akumal and he has a theory about the
Fantastic Four in the MCU Amir's theory
says that there was a five-year gap in
Avengers endgame and the Fantastic Four
could already exist in the universe just
not have been mentioned and since they
are scientists they want to explore what
actually happened with the snap so just
like the Avengers do they track down the
energy source on a different planet and
they go into space now we know that fan
o's reduced the Infinity stones to atoms
and Avengers in game and what if the
Fantastic Four on their space mission
run into these atoms this could be the
source of their powers and how they get
introduced into the MCU perhaps they
could even get introduced in the post
credits scene for spider-man far from
home because of the future foundation
this is certainly an interesting way to
bring the Fantastic Four into the MCU
and this actually works really well
because it's a way to retcon dumb into
the MCU to make it seem like they were
there the whole entire time however they
didn't get their powers until recently
in the MCU
they would have gotten their powers
right when
Avengers went and killed Thanos so it's
a good way to say that they've always
kind of been there but they only just
recently became the Fantastic Four and
Kevin Feige did say that the Fantastic
Four are probably the group that they're
going to introduce first from all of the
characters that they got from the Disney
Foxx deal so we could see them in the
MCU very soon and this would be a great
way to do it so that does it for all of
the theories in this week's episode of
Theory Thursday don't forget to vote on
which one was your favorite let's do a
quick recap theory number one is that
the new timeline that Loki created in
Avengers endgame is actually the same
timeline that Mysterio was from and Loki
could have even trained a Mysterio in
the art of Illusion theory number two is
that Red Skull is now furry and will end
up as a villain in the Falcon and Winter
Soldier series Theory number three is
that all of the spider-man suits that we
see in the spider-man fire from Hoenn
trailers are actually different
spider-man from different universes
theory number four is that the battle
world will come to the MCU and then the
superheroes and villains will all team
up against Doctor Doom and theory number
five is that the atoms of the Infinity
stones create the Fantastic Four in the
MCU so those are all this week's
theories be sure to vote on which one
you thought was your favorite and again
if you would like to submit your own
theory for a chance to end up in an
episode of Theory Thursdays you can find
the email to send it to and the
instructions in the description down
below be sure to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest
episodes of Theory Thursdays and so you
can stay up to date on everything
relating to Marvel as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you